là j'étais à l'Aiguille du Midi
au-dessus de chamony dans les Alpes et
là au Rocher des Aigles dans le périgor
et ça c'était pour un tournage sur les
flamanss roses ça fait toujours plaisir
de revoir des photos de vacances ou de
voyage je ne sais pas où vous rangez les
vottres mais je suppose que comme
beaucoup vouslai stocker sur un disque
dur comme celui-ci sauf que j'en ai
parlé avec Michell de la chaîne micod il
a un peu la dendure avec les disques
durs externes on vous explique tout
[Musique]
aujourd'hui et bien oui je crois que
aujourd'hui je vais briser un mythe non
le disque v n pas un outil fiable pour
conserver no fichier intact sur le long
terme et je sens que derrière leurs
écrans certains d'entre vous font la
grimace pourtant c'est la vérité pour
comprendre pourquoi un disque dur a une
durée de vie moyenne assez courte il
faut commencer par le commencement un
disque dur ça fonctionne comment
un disque dur se compose d'un ensemble
de plateaux ils peuvent être en
aluminium en verre ou en céramique mais
ce ne sont pas ces matériaux qui
abritent directement les données ce sont
les couches ferromagnétiques qui les
recouvrent ce sont les couches qui
permettent l'enregistrement des
informations codées ces disques tournent
très vite 5400 tours par minute voire
7200 mais pour écrire sur la surface
d'un disque il faut un élément
supplémentaire une tête d'écriture qui
fait aussi vos fil de tête de lecture ce
sont des électroéments capables de créer
un champ magnétique positif ou négatif
on appelle ça la polarisation magnétique
en fonction du sens de lément la tête
d'écriture code la surface du plateau 0
ou 1 elle commence par l'extérieur en
périphérie pour aller vers le centre du
disque l'opération effectué par la tête
d'écriture d'apparence simple est en
réalité très complexe le plateau d'un
disque qu'on appelle aussi galette a une
importante densité de stockage les têtes
de lecture et d'écriture doivent donc
être extrêmement précises elle survole
le plateau à une distance de l'ordre du
nanomètre 12000 fois plus petit qu'un
cheveux à la moindre poussière ou au
moindre petit choc la tête de lecture se
colle à la galette par adhésion
moléculaire elle se rayille et votre
disque est foutu et vous pouvez dire
adieu à vos données le fonctionnement
d'un disque dur c'est une prouesse
technologique un petit miracle l'aloé
directeur de recherche émérite CNRS
compare la distance de survol d'une tête
de lecture à un Concorde lancé à pleine
vitesse à seulement 1 m du sol cette
association entre des éléments
mécaniques d'un côté et une vitesse de
rotation très élevée de l'autre rend les
disques durs vraiment fragiles pour
l'anecdote chez un hébergeur de données
on m'avait demandé de toujours déplacer
les disques durs horizontalement plutôt
que
verticalement ça permet de minimiser le
risque de saut de la tête de lecture
c'est vrai qu'un accident est vite
arrivé le disque dur vous échappe des
mains et bim vous perzich j'en parle en
connaissance de cause comme ils sont
fragiles les disques durs ont une durée
de vie qui n'excède pas 5 à 7 ans en
moyenne bien sûr ils peuvent durer plus
longtemps mais il faut vraiment être
très très précautionneux heureusement
vous allez le voir il existe des
alternative au disque dur pour conserver
vos données commençons par les SSD Solid
State Drive ce sont les successeurs
directs des disques à plateau ce sont
eux qui équipent très souvent nos
ordinateurs aujourd'hui ils embarque ce
qu'on appelle de la mémoire flash elle
est aussi utilisée dans les cartes
mémoire de nos appareils photo dans les
clés USB et on comprend vite pourquoi
une grande résistance au choc aucun
élément mécanique n'entre en jeu plus
rapide et davantage miniaturisable la
mémoire flash est construite avec des
transistors composant de base de
l'informatique moderne ayant la capacité
d' piéger des électrons ainsi cet amas
d'électrons permet de stocker une valeur
binaire pourtant la mémoire flash n'est
pas la solution idéale elle est un peu
plus chère même si ça tend à se réduire
depuis quelques années et surtout ces
transistors utilisent un composé
chimique le dioxyde de silicium à la
durée de vie limitée on estime pouvoir
réécrire sur une mémoire flash 100000
fois alors ça peut paraître beaucoup dit
comme ça mais ça correspond environ à
une dizaine d'années en usage classique
et vaut mieux ne pas l'oublier dans un
placard non plus si elle est pas
utilisée une fois de temps en temps elle
risque de ne plus fonctionner du tout à
cause de ce fichu dioxyde de silicium
certains parmi vous vont peut-être se
dire dans ce cas autant utiliser un bon
vieux cédérum avec eux au moins les
informations sont sauvegardées pour
l'éternité sauf que là encore c'est une
très mauvaise idée je dirais même plus
cette idée est très très mauvaise dans
les années 80 c'était la bonne solution
contrairement aux galettes d'un un
disque dur le CD n'est en contact avec
rien c'est un laser qui vient lire une
fine couche d'aluminium son système est
très ingénieux il est fait de creux et
de boss invisiblebles à nos yeux grâce
auxquels les zé et les 1 sont stockés le
tout couronné d'un gros succès
commercial bref tout semblait parfait on
se voyait déjà sauvegarder nos archives
nationales dessus sauf que en 2003 on
découvre des pertes d'information dans
certains CD Rom on appelle ce phénomène
le CD rot ou la pourriture du CD des
petits points microscopiques se forment
à la surface du disque ce sont des
particules oxydées elles viennent percer
la couche d'aluminium contenant les
informations la lumière du laser ne peut
donc plus se réfléchir sur cette couche
d'alu les données sont perdues phénomène
accru lors d'une exposition à la lumière
et à des températures élevées on le
pensait increvable et pourtant le CD ou
le DVD ne sont pas des outil de stockage
sûr à long terme Jamy tu connais sans
doute ce dicton c'est dans les vieux
pots qu'onit fait les meilleures
confitures j'adore la confiture alors je
vais te parler d'un moyen de stockage
vieux comme le monde qui a été inventé à
une époque où toi et moi nous n'étions
pas né le microfilm il s'agit d'un film
photographique contenant des
reproductions de documents au format
très réduit vous savez les pellicules
qu'on utilise en photo argentique et ben
c'est la même chose mais en tout petit
le microfilm a été inventé par René
Dagron un photographe et inventeur
français en
1859 bien avant l'ère du numérique c'est
l'un des tout premiers supports de
stockage de documents utilisés par les
entreprises spécialement aux États-Unis
où il fait un tabac à salth Lake City
dans l'UTA les mormons les ont utilisé
pendant plus de 80 ans pour stocker les
états civils des populations de plus de
200 pays mais le microfilm a aussi ses
limites au début des années 2000 on
constate en effet que les bandes ont
tendance à gondoler et que des taches
brunâes se forment sur le support ce
film est recouvert d'une fine couche
constituée d'un mélange homogène de
cellulose et d'acide acétique avec le
temps ces deux composants se séparent
pour redonner d'un côté de la cellulose
et de l'autre de l'acide acétique ce
dernier a tendance à s'évaporer le film
se rétracte il ondule ce qui provoque la
perte d'information ce phénomène a été
baptisé syndrome du vinaigre tout simple
parce que les bandes sentaient le
vinaigre et pour cause l'acide acétique
c'est du vinaigre de grandes
bibliothèques d'archives comme
l'Institut national de l'audiovisuel
Lina en France ou encore la TSR
Télévision Suisse Romande ont dû
entreprendre un grand plan de
numérisation de toutes leurs bobines de
film la TSR a recensé des milliers de
bobines touchées par le syndrome du
vinaigre et les mormons dont tu nous as
parlé tout à l'heure ont fait exa
exactement la même chose en 2021 ils ont
annoncé avoir terminé la numérisation de
tous leurs microfilm ça leur a quand
même pris 25 ans il n'empêche que l'idée
du microfilm pour conserver des données
dans le temps n'est pas du tout mauvaise
jamis la bande magnétique reste ce qu'il
y a de plus efficace encore faut-il
trouver un moyen de les conserver dans
le temps c'est la question que l'on
s'est posée à Lina mais aussi au CNE
l'organisation pour la recherche
nucléaire c'est l'organisme qui exploite
le fameux LHC le plus grand accélérateur
de particules au monde situé à la
frontière entre la Suisse et la France
il se trouve que les expérimentations du
cerne génèent une quantité astronomique
de données qu'il n'est pas envisageable
de perdre en un mois le LH génère plus
de 12 PTA octé de données brutes c'est
l'équivalent de la mémoire de 200000
smartphones elles sont stockées sur des
disques durs dans un premier temps pour
être traité avant d'être archivé d'après
un rapport interne en 2020 les archives
du cerern comptent 320 PTA octé de
données de quoi enregistrer une vidéo HD
pendant 1000 ans pour conserver et
consulter cette ama considérable
d'information le cerern a fait un choix
la bonne vieille bande magnétique mais
sous une forme assez particulière le LTO
pour linear tape open c'est une
cartouche de plastique comme un jeu Game
Boy qui contient une bande magnétique
c'est résistant au choc ça ne consomme
pas d'électricité c'est bien plus fiable
qu'un disque dur de l'ordre de 1000 fois
c'est une technologie encore en
évolution une seule cartouche pourrait
atteindre une capacité de 50 ta octé
dans le futur et c'est pas si cher que
ça une cinquantaine d'euros la cartouche
de 6 T oct à l'heure actuelle on
considère que c'est la solution ultime
pour l'archivage de données le cerne en
possède plus de 50000 géré par des
robots seul bémol le prix d'un lecteur
de cartouche LTO plusieurs milliers
d'euros alle ça refroidit peut-on faire
mieux que la bande magnétique pour
archiver nos données pour le moment la
réponse est non mais un nouveau support
tout à fait étonnant est à l'étude il se
cache ici au cœur de nos cellules je
parle de l'ADN avec l'accélération et la
baisse des coups permettant la synthèse
et le séquençage de l'ADN nous
arriverons peut-être bientôt à utiliser
de l'ADN synthétique pour stocker nos
photos de vacances un seul gramme d'ADN
peut contenir
des centaines de pétaocté pour info un
pétaocté correspond à 1 million de gig
imaginez que l'ensemble des informations
contenues sur Internet pourrait tenir
sur un
support grand comme une tablette de
chocolat d'ailleurs Lina l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel s'intéresse de
très près à cet outil du futur pour
conserver nos archives et Michell ton
équipe a elle-même fait l'expérience
avec l'Institut Pasteur vous avez réussi
a stocker de l'information sur l'ADN je
me souviens et j'étais sur le plateau de
l'émission très impressionnant et oui
jamis on peut dire que nous sommes des
pionniers en revanche c'est une
opération encore trop coûteuse et trop
longue pour le moment une autre méthode
est à l'étude le stockage dans du quartz
matériaux très très résistant et stable
sa durée de vie est estimée entre 300
millions et plusieurs milliards d'années
l'idée est simple à l'aide d'un laser on
vient graver de l' information à
l'intérieur du quartz à l'abri des
poussières ou des rayures pouvant
survenir en surface et pour le lire un
simple microscope suffit c'est
passionnant mais ces solutions sont
expérimentales ou bien elles sont tort
de prix du coup on fait comment pour
protéger nos photos de vacances la
solution tient en une expression ne pas
mettre tous ces œufs dans le même panier
une donnée bien sauvegardé est une
donnée stockée sur différents supports
et dans différents lieux ça peut être
chez un ami par exemple ou encore plus
simple à l'aide d'un drive ces espaces
de stockage en ligne dans le Cloud comme
on dit souvent sont hébergés dans de
grands data center dans ces systèmes de
Drive nos données sont automatiquement
répliquées sur différents disques durs
et dans différents lieux pour prévenir
tout accident et perte de données vous
n'avez rien à faire tout est automatique
alors pourquoi pas y stocker quelques
photos que ce soit gratuitement pour une
faible quantité de données ou en payant
un abonnement pour un espace plus
important malgré son prix plus élevé si
si le drive est autant plébisité c'est
bien pour sa simplicité d'utilisation et
la tranquillité d'esprit qui va avec
merci Michel merci à vous toutes et tous
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo jusqu'à son
terme alors je sais ça fait beaucoup
d'infos mais l'avantage avec Youtube
c'est que si vous avez un problème de
mémoire vous pouvez revisionner la vidéo
autant de fois que vous le voulez allez
bonne semaine et à dimanche prochain
pour une nouvelle vidéo épic curieuse
érieuse